with the exception of these changes our
assumption based on recent case numbers
is that current levels will remain in
force until the 19th of july although
obviously
we continue to keep that under review
let me turn now to when we hope to lift
remaining restrictions now i want to be
clear that what i am about to set out
represents our best judgment at this
stage of what is likely to strike a
sensible balance
it is intended to give as much clarity
as possible
however it is contingent on meeting our
vaccination milestones and of course the
revised
strategic aim of alleviating the harms
of the virus
if the data in the coming weeks suggests
we can go faster we will do so
conversely if the data says we need to
slow down we will do that too though i
very much hope
that will not be necessary the next
scheduled review point will be the 19th
of july though we will confirm the
position
a week in advance as usual by the 19th
of july
three weeks will have elapsed since the
completion of the vaccination program
for over 50s which means that the
vaccine will be giving everyone in that
age group a significant level
of protection therefore assuming we're
meeting the revised strategic aim we
hope that all parts of scotland
not currently in that level will move to
level zero
on the 19th of july that means for
example that the limits for household
gatherings indoors will increase from
that date and up to 200 people will be
able to attend weddings
and funerals we also hope assuming the
data supports this that the general
indoor physical distancing requirement
it can be reduced from two meters
to one meter from that date and we hope
also from that date to lift the outdoor
requirement to physically
distance altogether in addition in
recognition of the reduced risk of
outdoor transmission and therefore the
desire to encourage people to stay
outdoors as much as possible
especially over the summer we hope that
limits on informal outdoor social
gatherings and private gardens for
example will be removed at this stage
so rather than the current rules for
level 0 which state that
up to 15 people from 15 households can
be outdoors
informal social gatherings of any size
will be allowed
we will however keep in place
temporarily the rules and processes
currently applicable at level zero
for organized outdoor events given these
can attract much larger crowds
if we can move as hoped to level zero on
the 19th of july that
will be a significant step back to
normality
but we have always been clear that level
zero cannot be an end point
some of the restrictions it entails are
still significant for example
the household limit for indoor
gatherings so we want to move
beyond level zero as quickly as it is
prudent to do so
the updated strategic framework sets out
what that means
in short well we're still likely to need
some baseline measures
it means the lifting of the remaining
major legal restrictions
in reaching a view on when that can be
done we have considered the harm to
health and the strain on the nhs
that could be caused if coveted cases
continue to rise and i must stress to
parliament that even with a reduced
ratio of cases to hospitalization case
numbers at the level being recorded just
now
could still put significant pressure on
the nhs we must be mindful of that
but we have also considered the wider
harms that restrictions cause
and we have considered how reasonable
and proportionate it is to require
people to comply
with these legal restrictions as we meet
vaccine milestones and if evidence
continues to show as we hope it will
that vaccination is protecting more and
more people from serious health impacts
i mentioned earlier that we expect to
have completed second doses for all over
40s by 26 july
we know that the protective effect of
the second dose takes a bit of time to
build up but within two weeks by 9th
august
we would expect the vast majority of
over 40s to have a significant level of
protection
of course we need to remember that
vaccination doesn't provide 100
protection and it won't be until later
in september that all adults will have
the protection
of full vaccination however our
assessment
on balance and assuming that we meet the
necessary conditions on vaccination
and harm reduction is that it would be
possible and proportionate to lift the
major
remaining legal restrictions on the 9th
of august
we will consider and make a final
assessment nearer the time of whether as
we hope
this could include the lifting of the
legal requirement to physically distance
indoors as well as outdoors
the move beyond levels level zero will
be a major
milestone and it will signal a return to
almost complete normality
in our day-to-day lives of course while
this is a longed for moment
it is important to recognize that we
still have a difficult path
to navigate over the next few weeks to
meet these milestones
and even assuming we do as we hope we
will the pandemic will not be completely
over
at this stage as our strategic framework
update paper sets out
basic mitigations will still be required
as we move
through summer and into the autumn when
we face the risk of a further resurgence
in cases
measures such as rigorous and regular
hand washing cleaning surfaces and good
ventilation will continue to be vital
and even if as we hope to we lift the
legal requirement we may still advise
keeping a careful distance
from people outside our closed contact
groups especially if they
are not fully vaccinated also at least
for a period we are likely to require
continued wearing of face coverings in
certain settings for example shops
and public transport test and protect
will also remain a vital part of our
approach
regular testing will still be advised
for a period at least and while we are
considering the impact of vaccination on
self-isolation
isolation will continue to be necessary
in certain circumstances especially for
those
who test positive there'll also be a
need to manage outbreaks as in when they
arise
and the level system will still be
available to help us do that
if necessary we all hope that we will
not see
a further variant against which our
vaccines are less effective
but we do need to retain the ability to
respond if that happens
both with updated vaccines and if
necessary with other measures
also we will not advise an immediate
return to full office working on the 9th
of august instead we will continue to
work with business
to agree an appropriate phasing of this
beginning
when we enter level zero we hope on the
19th of july
however i think many would agree that as
a general principle homeworking should
be
more possible post covered than it was
before
so while recognizing that a return to
the workplace it will be right for many
we will encourage continued support for
home working where that is possible and
appropriate
this won't just assist with control of
the virus it will also help promote
well-being more generally
and while we will continue to keep the
need for travel restrictions under
review it is likely that some targeted
restrictions will be needed
after 9th august as new variants
continue to pose the biggest threat to
our progress
finally we'll also work over the summer
to plan for the return of schools
colleges and universities
for the moment though i want to take the
opportunity to say a heartfelt thank you
to everyone
in education most schools and many
early learning and childcare settings
are about to break for the summer
holidays
colleges and universities are also
needing the end of term
for everyone working in education this
will have been the toughest
and most distressing year of your
professional career
i am grateful for everything you have
done to keep nurseries and childcare
facilities schools colleges and
universities
going in such difficult circumstances we
will be working to do everything
possible to minimize
any further covert disruption in the
next academic term
exciting officer we must remember that
this is a global pandemic
it will not be completely over here
until it is over
across the world unfortunately the world
is still some way
from that however here in scotland while
transmission is causing concern
at the moment vaccination is giving us
much of the protection
the only harsh restrictions have been
able to give us so far
so that means we can now plan to move
much more firmly and with much greater
confidence
from the need to control the virus
through tough restrictions to being able
to
live much more freely that is good news
we must be careful still but from the
19th of july
and then more substantially from the 9th
of august assuming
we are meeting our revised strategic aim
of alleviating the harm of the virus
life should feel it much much less
restricted for all of us
a very significant degree of normality
will be restored
for individuals and for businesses as i
said earlier
these are indicative dates but they
allow us to plan ahead with more clarity
as always though we all have a part to
play in keeping us
on track so i will end with a reminder
of the key asks of
everyone across the country the first is
vaccination please get vaccinated when
invited to do so and please attend
for both doses if you need to rearrange
or if you think you should have had an
invitation by now
please go to the vaccination section of
the nhs and forum website
if you've had at your first dose of the
vaccine eight weeks or more ago
check on the website to see if you can
bring your second dose forward
secondly please do test yourself
regularly
free lateral flow tests are available
through nhs and form
they can be ordered through the post are
collected from local and regional test
sites and also now of course from
community pharmacies
if you test positive please self-isolate
and get the result confirmed through a
pcr test
and finally please continue to stick to
the rules where you live and follow all
the public health advice
this is still really important the virus
is
still out there and it is spreading so
please continue to follow advice on
physical distancing
hand washing and face coverings try to
meet others outdoors as much as possible
we know that no environment is entirely
risk-free but outdoors is much less
risky than
indoors if you are meeting indoors
though please stick to the limits for
now
and make sure the room is well
ventilated
and that does apply when watching at the
football
too we all know that tonight's game is
absolutely
massive let me take the opportunity i'm
sure on behalf of all of us to wish
steve clark
and the team well we will all be
cheering scotland on this evening
but please do it safely and do it within
the rules
presenting officer six months ago when i
confirmed to parliament that tough
restrictions were being
reimposed it was the day after the
winter solstice
the shortest night of the year that was
one of the darkest moments in the course
of this pandemic
for these past 15 months we have endured
restrictions that would have been
considered
impossible just two years ago the pain
suffered and the people lost along the
way
it must never be forgotten they will
never be forgotten
and in a global global pandemic we can't
be certain that there won't be difficult
moments yet to come but i
hope and i believe that today's
statement just of course a day after the
summer solstice
marks a positive turning point we are
now
living in more hopeful times we can now
see a route to lifting
restrictions and to enjoying again the
simple but precious pleasures that we've
all missed so much
the path ahead is not obstacle free i'm
not going to pretend it is
but it is clearer now than at any point
so far
thanks to vaccines normal life is now
much closer it is
within sight so let's all stick with it
and do whatever is required
to get us there